what's up guys bang bang this was a big
week for Bitcoin Bitcoin wallet
addresses on chain that have at least
one Bitcoin officially crossed over one
million users that's right on chain one
million different wallet addresses now
hold at least one full Bitcoin it's a
hell of a lot of full Bitcoin owners on
top of that we saw Robert Kennedy Jr at
the Bitcoin conference he said that he
believes Bitcoin is an exercise of
democracy here's a Quick Clip and so I
want to thank all of you guys for for
coming here and all of you for
supporting this I know everybody is so
passionate about Bitcoin not just
because it's a currency but because it's
an exercise in democracy and when I'm
president I'm gonna make sure that you
got your own wallet that you keep your
own passport password that the
government can't interfere with it that
nobody's gonna be taxing your
electricity 30 and going into your
computers and and taking those intrusive
measurements and that weekend nurture
this product at home in America where
it's going to create an infrastructure
and create wealth for Americans so thank
you all very much
if we then take a look not only is
Robert Kennedy Jr excited about Bitcoin
Paul Tudor Jones was interviewed earlier
this week by Andrew Ross Sorkin CNBC and
Paul Tudor Jones said he's sticking with
Bitcoin he already said that it was
going to be the fastest horse and he's
still riding that horse here's what Paul
had to say about Bitcoin Bitcoin it came
on our air yep during the early part of
the pandemic I think it was trading at
eight nine thousand dollars a coin yep
and you said I'm in yep and I think you
wrote it all the way up to 60 some odd
thousand dollars and we then wrote it
back down to fifteen thousand dollars
and we're now sitting I think somewhere
around twenty seven thousand dollars
I've never sat on a horse that long just
just so
what's the you're still on the horse
though I I from the beginning I've
always said I want to have a small
allocation to it because it's a great
tale event it's the only thing that
humans can adjust the supply in so I
sticking with it I'm gonna always stick
with it as just a small diversification
in my portfolio what do I think right
now I I liked it last December I still
think I I mean would you buy more right
now would I buy more I I would probably
I'm kind of I look it in gold and I
think
they've done so well recently because of
the fact that we have had these great
risk premiums I wonder I wonder
I wonder whether they may not be boring
in the future like so big Bitcoin has a
real problem because the United States
you have the entire regulatory apparatus
against it so it's just kind of
yesterday's news and if inflation's
truly done a bit if it's if that if that
story's been played then you have to
wonder we were buying gold and Bitcoin
for the inflation Hedges that game may
be over I would have I would ins six
months ago before AI before the possible
productivity boost that we'll get for it
I would have saw said a completely
different story
with regard to inflationary future
and with regard to all the inflation
hedge now Paul Tudor Jones and Robert
Kennedy Jr they come from two completely
different worlds but if we bring it
right back to people in the Bitcoin and
crypto industry we see that tether they
now are going to take 15 of all of their
profits and use it to buy Bitcoin that
will be consistent persistent buying
pressure in the market Bitcoins up about
60 to start the year and as we see more
and more people dollar costs averaging
in seeing the 1 million Bitcoin
addresses with at least one Bitcoin on
it and then all of these people from
tether Paul Tudor Jones and Robert
Kennedy Jr coming out in support of
Bitcoin tells you that bitcoin's not
over and it's probably likely that
bitcoin's got a bright future ahead hope
you enjoy these updates see you next
Saturday